recently came across an article that
made me realize that marriage just isn't
for me
and I know it's unfortunate because it
took me five years to realize it that it
isn't for me and babe I know you're
probably gonna be watching this as well
hang in there so you understand what I
mean by this so the article was written
by Seth Adam Smith on November 3rd title
marriage isn't for you and it was on
Huffington Post first they got 50,000
likes on Facebook and it's a story about
a guy that dated his girlfriend since he
was 15 years old 10 years they were
together finally they came to the
position the point of having to get
married and he started having all these
fears these anxieties should I do this
is she for me am i for can I handle this
should I stay single and he went to his
father and I love fatherly advice
because it's pure wisdom speaking to
your life experience speaking to your
right and he asked a question it said
that his marriage for me and this is the
response father gave to him his father
said Seth you're being totally selfish
so I'm going to make this really simple
marriage isn't for you you don't marry
to make yourself happy you marry to make
someone else happy
more than that your marriage isn't for
yourself you're married for a family not
just for the in-laws and all the
nonsense but for your future children
who do you want to help you raise them
who do you want to influence them
marriage isn't for you it's not about
you marriage is about the person you
marry so I thought his father made some
very good points in the state nobody
continues to say true marriage is never
about you it's about the person you love
their wants their needs their hopes
their dreams selfishness demands what's
in it for me what love asks what can I
give you know every once in a while I
come across articles like this that give
me wisdom from somebody that I can
implement in my life right away that I
want to share with other people so with
that being said be sure to
if you want to read this helpful to post
article further click on the link on the
description